the texas-mexico border is seeing record
numbers of migrants trying to cross into
the u.s and start a new life in march
border officials reported more than
221 thousand encounters along the
southwest land border that is nearly 28
percent more than last march texas
governor greg abbott says he launched
operation lone star last year to respond
to these big increases in crossings the
project diverts billions of dollars in
state taxpayer money toward border
protection lilia luciano went to the
border and rode along with the texas
department of public safety to gauge the
success of the operation this morning
she's in mission texas in the rio grande
valley leah lilia rather good morning
good morning to you jamie well we spent
the last two days touring the border by
land air and water to get a deeper
understanding of exactly how operation
lone star works and why is texas
spending about three billion dollars of
taxpayer money on efforts that are
mostly under the jurisdiction of the
federal government something that
critics of governor greg abbott have
called an expensive political stunt but
the governor says is necessary to secure
the border
where are you headed so now we just one
of the troopers got an alert on a camera
that went off so that's what we're
responding to another ranch that's
lieutenant chris olivares of the texas
department of public safety his team's
mission operation lone star it's a
state-run taxpayer-funded operation
governor greg abbott launched last march
to deter migrants from crossing the
border for the most part you know a lot
of them that we've talked to they're
saying they're trying to get to san
antonio or houston
and they're looking for work
but of course
within those groups you do have
criminals because the federal government
and not states have the power to enforce
immigration law state troopers in
lieutenant olivarez's team can only
arrest people for trespassing onto
certain private ranches they reach
across the border
using choppers
boats mexico is right there yeah can't
miss it drones and cameras on the ground
to coordinate locations they're headed
east yeah they're headed towards us
these men were handcuffed and charged
with trespassing a misdemeanor being out
there being able to make these
apprehensions and also keep the ranchers
safe that's the most important thing so
it's kind of a security for the ranchers
well not just ranchers too but also for
the entire country because what we do
know that these individuals are not
staying in texas governor abbott says
dps is meant to protect texans they have
apprehended more than 200 000 migrants
so far
they've arrested more than eleven
thousand including cartel members drug
smugglers and cop killers but according
to a pro-publica texas tribune and the
marshall project investigation more than
two thousand of those charges stopped
being counted because they were
unrelated to illegal activity at the
border meanwhile operation lone star
cost texas taxpayers about two and a
half million dollars per week and ten
thousand texas national guard members
have been sent to the border to aid in
apprehensions under the program with no
end in sight still some private property
owners are taking matters into their own
hands this whole long wall was built by
a private property owner the owner of
this land built it up and on the ends of
the wall and the gaps that's where dps
and the texas national guard are
surveilling the dps boats armed with
heavy weaponry patrol the rio grande
river primary goal the mission is to
stop the criminal activity from taking
place from entering the state of texas
and making it further into the interior
that sounds a lot like border
enforcement right but that's not up to
states that's up to the federal
government well but one thing to
understand is that operational star is a
comprehensive border strategy because
the federal government has failed to
take any type of action or have a
strategy in place
to stop some of the criminal activity
but given the high number of crossings
that deterrence strategy may not be
working
this is your fourth time trying to come
in this month
why do you keep coming
in
they told us they weren't intending to
commit crimes and all they have left is
that and a broken dream
haven't done these ride-alongs now for
years along the border with border
patrol i was struck by the massive
number of troopers that are deployed
from all over texas into just a handful
of counties to do these trespassing
arrests within only the ranches that
they're permitted to by the owners so
you have to wonder if they're not there
they still have to call border patrol
whether they encounter asylum seekers or
in areas that they're not authorized you
have to wonder if they weren't there
would border patrol be the ones to just
come in and detain the same number of
people tony
yeah meanwhile it's costing the state of
texas three billion dollars pretty big
price tag and pretty big guns on those
boats as well lilia thank you very much
for eye-opening report